7h30 ce jeudi matin une des deux voies
de rer c au niveau de la gare de saint
quentin en yvelines connaît un défaut
d'alimentation un train reste bloqué la
situation a duré une partie de la
matinée mais les voyageurs ont pu
repartir avec des retards de 10 à 15
minutes environ
la sncf assure que le trafic devrait
reprendre son cours progressivement qui
a été perturbé je pense qu'on pourra
faire une réparation provisoire qui
s'achèvera je pense en début d'après
midi ce qui nous permettra d'assurer un
trafic quasi normal pour la poigne de
soirée et ensuite on fait une réparation
définitive dans la nuit nous permettra
d'avoir à nouveau la plénitude de nos
installations de vale à tort lignes de
transilien n et u ont également été
perturbés sur les quais les voyageurs
ont été informés très tôt de la
situation et la sncf a distribué aux
usages est restée bloquée ce mot
d'excusé pour justifier le retard des
salariés